the ramsay show you can be
intentional about your character you can
have money
and a career you are the hero in your
story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsay
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host thank you for
joining us america dr john deloney
ramsey personality
host of the dr john daloni show big time
podcast these days is my co-host
open phones here as we talk about your
life he can do that and i'll interject
and your money i can do that and
sometimes he interjects
the phone number triple eight eight two
five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five two two nathaniel's in raleigh
north carolina hi nathaniel how are you
hey dave uh thanks for taking my call um
absolutely i've gotten a lot of we our
family's gotten a lot of benefits out of
your
baby steps so thank you we're on babies
up too way to go
my question is um we have been dependent
on
our parents i'm married i have three
children but we've been to parent
dependent on our parents basically the
whole time we've been married about five
years
we've recently come into a larger sum of
money from the stimulus checks and
tax refunds stuff like that and we've
been trying to live independently from
them and paying off our debts
now but the question i'm wondering is
should i just take
all the money we have every dollar put
it on
all our debt and get help now or try to
stave off their health as long as
possible and be independent
with the high probability that in about
a year we're probably going to need to
ask for help again
why do you need so much help man what
what is it about your life that
you can't make it because you went from
help from mom and dad
then you went from help from the
government right
right what's what's the problem um so
the main problem there's a couple of
things my wife is chronically ill
okay um she's got like she had a botched
scoliosis surgery as a child and has a
lot of chronic pain so we spend a lot of
money
on physical therapists and
rehabilitation and trying to figure that
piece of the puzzle out okay and and so
that that takes up
a lot of of the money and then it's been
some you know help and similar to that
she has some dietary issues that help
with her condition
with some because you have some muscle
elasticity and inflammation issues so
that runs up our bill a fair amount and
so
and also i think there's been a couple
improved career jumps that i had i had
from liberal arts degree to
easy think tank to um
corporate philanthropy to teacher to now
accountant
so that that too so trying to figure
that
out and i think i probably made more
jumps than i needed to so that's
that's why we've needed help in the past
so what do you make
i make about 57 000 a year okay
and what does your wife what do you
spend on your wife's medical care
um last month when we were doing our
budget this the first may was our first
budgeted month
um it was probably over 500
dollars and then we also had to pay for
frenectomy for
our infant our third child and that was
like 600
on top of that yeah but that's that's
only one time thing your wife says more
your wife is right your wife's situation
is more chronic and so
yeah and the uh food situation for your
wife costs an
extra how much i'd say we spend about
we spent close to twenty five hundred
dollars on groceries this month
that's that's ex that's an extraordinary
amount of money
and you're talking to a guy that is so
obnoxious about what i put in my body
we overspend at our house and you have
almost tripled what i spend
right obnoxious to the point that my
wife rolls her eyes at me
right something isn't clicking here
so you so you're just saying i need to
reduce the food bill i mean
and that's what we're doing right now
with i mean we're trying to do the
budget and making sure that that's true
i think there's a lot i i i listen
number one
neither one of us are uh
saying that we don't that we would we
would not suggest that you don't take
good care of your wife
right ever okay right um
however sometimes when you're dealing
with chronic pain and chronic issues
uh the emotions around that can
sometimes justify
a different level of stupidity
and that's what we're calling out
right so i mean 500 bucks a month
did not scare me on medical that's six
thousand dollars a year
you've got a chronic situation that's
very possible
okay i can that one i can i can chew on
and
making fifty seven thousand dollars a
year plus picking up some ot here or
there or doing some other stuff
doing some tax returns or something if
you're an accountant to pick up some
extra money you you can we can handle
that with three kids
you can make progress and live on sixty
thousand dollars a year
and without your parents helping without
the government's help
okay now the 2500 food bill though
something's really screwed up there
you're going to fix that
and still figure out a way to feed her
food that does not cause her issues
okay so it's really about just attacking
things so i guess then the other
question is like
to that point is should it really just
be really try not to get help from our
parents
i think it's really curious that you're
getting help from your parents if you
make 60 000
a year and have three kids okay and
i want you to flip the question how much
debt do you have
uh well so i have about fifty six
thousand dollars in student debt we paid
off a credit card with the money that we
got
um and then but now i've been thinking
about it my
wife has a loan that her parents said
they would pay but it's in her name
that i do not know the amount of that
i'm guessing is about twenty thousand
dollars
how much you owe in your cars uh nothing
nothing we our cars are gonna guess okay
any other big debt you're leaving out of
this discussion so far
no we're on we're we're renting right
now but we're renting
more in a more expensive place so much
i would like 1900 a little rich okay
so let me tell you what's running
through my head i'll just share openly
and this is how i'm kind of making some
of these judgment calls and then you can
go make them because you're obviously a
sharp guy
okay you have three kids and you make
almost exactly the average household
income in america
and the average household in america has
2.5 kids so i mean you are like average
average average average
money-wise okay and so you ought to be
able to live on that
that's what's running through my head
now you mix in there you got some debt
and you which most people do
and we're going to help you get out of
that and you mix in there your wife's
medical issues
and that puts an extra strain on it but
it does not break the camel's back
uh so yeah you need to get on top of
this and and
you guys need to cut your freaking
lifestyles and stay out of restaurants
and you're not going on vacation until
you get some of this stuff straightened
up
but that's everybody that's not just you
wherever right
yeah we don't eat out just because my
wife can't okay you know yeah that makes
sense that makes sense and
but here's the thing when you have this
much
physical pain in the family
chronic pain it begins to affect all
decision making
and that's where i was going to aim to
he hit his
we got like a sliver into his life where
i'm going from job to job to job to job
man when home is hard and someone that
you love is in pain and hurting
man it's easy to go chasing yeah
happiness enjoyed other places well and
um you're looking for the one thing
that's right you're looking for a silver
bullet yeah i just i could just get that
one thing
if i could just get that one thing i'm
gonna try this i'm gonna try if i could
just get that one thing and and
and that's a normal thing and it's a
type of desperation and every time i get
desperate right after that i'm stupid
a hundred percent of the time and so um
you know i think you settle in on this
job you look for some stuff you can do
at home after everybody's asleep
do it a lot of stuff and you make some
extra money
and you tighten up this budget and you
begin to get your hands around
the emotional parts of managing through
this pain
as well as the financial parts and it'll
be the first time in your life and it's
time
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to puretalk
they use the same network as the larger
providers for much less
for just 30 dollars a month get
unlimited talk text
and six gigs of data with no contract
the average family saves over 70 dollars
a month
by switching to pure talk just go to
puretalk.com
and enter the promo code ramsey to save
50
off your first month pure talk simply
smarter wireless
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host
today this is the ramsey show chris is
in omaha
nebraska hi chris welcome to the ramsey
show
gentlemen how you doing today thanks for
having me absolutely how can we help
so a couple years ago um we had our
second child
and uh during all the prenatal
appointments and everything
um some things got screwed up um on
their end
and we got billed for a fourteen hundred
dollar
doctor bill um and we went round and
round between insurance
and the doctor that apparently never got
settled because
we just got hit with uh collections
agency for that fourteen hundred dollars
um i talked to the lady at collections
tried to negotiate for a lower amount
or something and she said no we're not
that kind of collections
you have to pay at all
looking for some guidance here i'm not
that kind of girl
yes you are
yes you are that kind of girl
oh my gosh what about what a load of
crap
okay so uh have you gone back to the
dock yet
um well actually we we've since
moved that was when we lived i don't
care if it's been a couple years i got
phones there
okay you hadn't called the doctor's
office yet and go hey
butts i'm getting a bill from you people
that was part of the rigmarole between
you know hey why isn't insurance
covering this and
why are we getting a bill that was part
of the whole rigmarole a couple of years
ago okay well let me let me
let me kind of let's lay a foundation
here all right sometimes
including you people get the idea that
because
insurance is supposed to pay something i
don't legally owe it
you do so you have a bill with a doctor
for x number of thousands and thousands
of dollars and you
owe 100 of that bill you are liable for
it
you're the consumer of that service you
owe the bill you however purchased from
a third party
insurance that is supposed to pay some
of the doctor bill
that you owe if they do not pay it it
does not remove you from liability
you owe the doctor bill and so since
insurance has not paid this if it's a
valid bill you owe it
now what you do can do is go back and
shoot through their butt and go why
didn't you people run this through
insurance properly
which you've already done once why
didn't they fix it then
i'm asking you why didn't they fix it
then oh gotcha so
they said well we did run it through
insurance properly but the insurance
didn't get the referral
and the right paperwork in time so that
insurance said well we can't backdate it
so you know we're not paying so the
doctor did not submit it to the
insurance company properly
uh yes okay then i'm chewing their butt
and saying guys you need to write this
off instead of holding me to it
because you didn't do your job
okay and that's the conversation you
should have had back then and now you
get to have now
and they get to pull it back out of
collections uh or
you get on the dock and you finally go
okay because but you need to start with
the premise chris that you do owe the
money
legally sure and you can't go before the
judge if you get sued and go well
insurance is supposed to pay it
because he's just going to laugh and go
insurance saying my problem dude you
have a contract with the doctor the
contract's broken because you can pay
the bill
now now however the doctor's office
part of the service they're supposed to
provide you
as well as the labor and delivery is to
take care of insurance paperwork in the
proper order
that way they get their freaking money
and since they didn't do that i would
challenge them
that this is their problem it's not
legally their problem it's morally and
business-wise their problem
does that make sense yes sir yeah
legally if they don't file
any paperwork they can come after you
for all of the bill
they can just throw up their hands and
go we're totally incompetent
we're not filing nothing and we're gonna
own chris
okay they can do that legally but it's
it's a horrible way to run a doctor's
office
it's a pr bad practice management and
you're gonna tell everybody you know not
to go everybody over there so
uh yeah i'm gonna call the office
administrator and have a discussion with
them i mean calmly and kindly but firmly
go guys this is on you it was your lack
of competence
and you should not be trying to bill us
for something as you didn't file the
insurance paperwork part of the service
you provide
as well as labor and delivery is to take
care of filing the prop paperwork in
prop
proper and timely manner and you did not
do that and now you turn it over to
collections and these bozos
who says she's not a girl like that and
she is coming after me it's ridiculous
and so that's how you handle it now at
the end of the day you're going to end
up settling this with the doctor's
office hopefully for pennies on the
dollar
so get ready to write a 500 check part
of that's on you because you didn't
settle this back when it was hot
when the deal's hot when there's a
problem you can't just walk away and go
i wish it was okay
it's always going to come out of the
closet later and get you i'm
right in the middle of a dealing with
this exact same thing
and with the bill and um it's
frustrating
and you got to continue to make that
phone call well here's a funny one
so sharon was at rachel's uh first book
tour
party launch party and i'm in the truck
heading to the airport and i get a call
and
sharon passed out and so she just had
a blood iron or something i mean it's
five years ago
and lobe iron or something and was
excited and everything or whatever and
and so they load her up in an ambulance
and take her to the dock and i go down
the emergency room she's okay she's
embarrassed she's like i'm all right am
i right am i right
okay so i never thought anything else
about it again so i started getting
these phone calls
for collection for a bill in collections
me
somebody's calling me and i'm going well
you got this is this is absolutely bull
crap there's no possible way i have a
bill out in collection
that's just ridiculous and so i'm just
like i'm just hanging up on the guy you
know
whatever i'm talking to him and so
finally the guy just
they just they're wearing me out and so
i turned it over i gave it to our
attorney
our staff legal counsel here i said hey
man call these guys and straighten this
out tell them i'm getting ready
own me a little collection agency
because i obviously do not owe an
outstanding bill that's gone to
collections is ridiculous
well he digs around fight figure out his
ambulance bill
oh goodness i did owe the money uh the
400
ambulance bill and i never got a bill
okay they never billed me they just
jumped it in collections and then this
little idiot's calling me with a headset
on you know
and this kind of stuff so i i did owe
the bill i ended up having to pay it but
but uh i'm just ignoring the guy just
and i wasn't because i i just thought it
was bogus i'm the i'm in that you cannot
ignore it i i even tried it you cannot
ignore it it comes back chris
and then they start tacking fees on it
well they're trying yeah that didn't
work either
i i i looked at them i went to the
emergency room on christmas day
with a poison ivy uh i it's a whole
other
no i don't want nobody you don't worry
but listen how do you get poison ivy in
the middle winner no don't tell me i'm
not gonna tell you
um it's a way that only delaney can yeah
but i looked in the eye and said if i
pay you cash can we shake hands walk out
and their eyes lit up you're gonna pay
us cash in a rural er
absolutely what you got and i told them
a number
and i said dave i looked at this this
human being it was during cove through
the
through an ipad and i said you promised
me i don't need any more money we're
gonna shake hands and walk out of here.
and she said absolutely
i'm asking one more time and you're
recording this right she said yep
we shook hands it was good it was an
obnoxious amount of money but it's my
own downfall for getting poison ivy in
december that's what i get i went home
got it i got a bill and it was a big one
a big bill and i said what in the world
they said well that was for the hospital
the doctor has a different charge and i
said that's like me going to burger king
and getting a number two combo and then
three months later the fry guy
sends me a bill at my house that's part
of the package
i thought the doctor was the key part of
the emergency room service
evidently not and so now i've got this
do i want to lose sleep and go to war
over 200 bucks
or nope but kind of i do dave
well yeah i do i know you you want to
but i'm just saying do you want to
so the uh i get the want to part but the
uh
here's the thing it turns out that you
can be in the medical industry
and be horrible at business practices
and math
why apparently i mean because they've
survived that way for decades now
i mean every one of you listening out
there has a horror story with some
stupid butt medical bill
everybody does i mean i actually was
auditing
a customer who's about to go bankrupt
one time and they got charged
46 dollars a piece for advil
[Music]
46 dollars per tablet
uh i can't make this crap i love america
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host in the lobby of ramsey solutions
on the debt free stage barry and amber
are with us hey guys how are you
good good how are you better than i
deserve welcome where do you live
we live right here in nashville oh
nashville my gosh we have a nashville
debt free screen we haven't had that i
don't know when that's awesome
so you just like drove like from your
neighborhood
wow very cool so how much have you paid
off it is just over 78 thousand dollars
very cool and your range of income
during or that
how long did that take that's okay uh we
took 30 months
all right and your range of income
during that two and a half years it
started at 95 and ended at 115.
yep very good what do you guys do for a
living i am a erp director
and i am a substitute teacher at our
local elementary school cool which
school
uh harpist valley elementary oh yeah
dogs
oh hound dogs that's famous famous yes
the harpeth valley pta
i've never ever heard of a school with
that cool of a mascot go hound dogs i
love it
yeah gin you see riley there's a song if
you just if you were old enough
old-time country but yeah that's it
that's cool very cool y'all
i love it so how much debt or the 78 000
what kind of debt was that
so it was a mix like most we had medical
that we started with
and then auto and credit cards and
lastly my student loan so you're kind of
normal
very normal yep how long you guys have
been married 15 years
15 years they're looking at each other
to confirm this conversation
yeah nobody's in trouble but we're both
checking okay
you guys pulled that first consonant to
make sure yeah it's not the same number
so uh what happened two and a half years
ago
we had a bit of a breakdown yep
yep there was no more bank transfers
on our credit cards that were available
and the money wasn't
increasing like we you know had hoped
and
we had to make a change so we just sat
down and there wasn't too much month
left at the end of the money
yeah yeah it was pretty devastating
that's an emotional night it
it was it really was it was a very
uncomfortable
conversation that was ready to be had
it's the ultimate oh crap moment so it's
been building and building and building
and building and then you just kind of
hit the wall and you go
uh oh yeah we went from a double income
um to one oh and so
um that didn't help either and we
continue to live in our same pace
and you know you can only go so far yeah
so amber when you
when dave just asked you that you still
remember that night like it was
i do five minutes ago it's still all
over you yeah
still sitting on the bed tell us what
happened and we had this conversation
and you know basically what you said
like there wasn't enough money at the
end of the month
and we had the are you going to go back
to work like double our income
but day care or child care here in
nashville is
exorbitant and i said financially that
wouldn't make sense
and so luckily they were at the age
where they were both getting ready to be
in school
and i said well i can start subbing and
i hit the ground running
and that you know with a budget the
budget helped a lot
yeah so but you changed your ways that
night you did more than just pick up a
job you said okay
so what you you like i suddenly remember
dave ramsey lived in nashville or what
was what happened i mean
i have been telling my husband about you
for years
uh-oh and i was doing the money
and i was like well if you don't want to
do this like then you do the money
oh and he's like i could do this oh yeah
until he couldn't
and i was like see like it's tough so it
was tough
yeah so then so then
we continued for a couple of years just
i'm saying it that that night sitting on
the bed okay i'm gonna start subbing
yeah and you said all right i'm gonna
figure out how to do this because the
way we've been doing it's not working
enrolled in financial pieces okay that's
what i was trying to figure out where
you got new information that changed
that's
yeah so you jumped into a financial
peace class we did okay we did and then
when that was finished
there she is third lady lily um i ended
up teaching one myself
oh wow i wanted to stay accountable yeah
and so
he watched the kids and i went and
taught the class and
30 months later we were done 30 long
months
that's pretty cool because you were you
were popping like a couple grand a month
on this we were
over 2500 every little bit we could get
our hands on yeah
you were hitting it hard yep and we cut
out a lot of stuff
a lot of we made lifestyle changes to
you know not go out to eat we made we
did only just the basic um
travel we told our friends we'll see you
when you come to our house and we can
cook you dinner and we can spend time
together
but yeah the but nashville for us i
think was a blessing because
we wouldn't have been able to do that
back home like there's so much to do
here that you don't need
money for and so we just
started doing all that and then covet
hit and we literally couldn't go
anywhere and spend money so yeah
that accelerates everything it really
did it did yes as long as you're able to
work
yes and you were so yeah that's good
news
wow so you go from
your throat is tight your stomach's in
your throat uh
that moment's like you said sitting on
the bed yeah and uh sometimes it's
sitting at the kitchen table and there's
bills laying all over the table
and you just kind of have a miniature
breakdown there and
you go from that to having a game plan
and having hope how long did that
transition take
from freaked out to hopeful i would say
it was in the first probably three
months
when we finished our fpu course we had
paid off one of our biggest credit cards
that the intro rate was about to expire
and
it was like just a few months into it
seeing like we can do this
you know we don't have to live miserably
thinking we're okay anymore and so
yeah it was it took a few months but you
know seeing that
debt paid off and that payment rolled to
the next one we had an excel sheet
and so seeing that snowball just get
bigger and bigger and bigger
was really motivating for us yeah
absolutely yeah
so what does it what does it feel like
now we can breathe
a lot less stress yeah um we dropped our
car off
this morning on our way here um for some
work we don't know what's going on with
it
and it's okay it's just it's annoying
right it's annoying
we're going to pay for it out of our
bank account and not have to worry about
yeah where is it coming from it's not a
it's not a thing anymore so barry what
was it like
you're a successful guy um you've got a
beautiful family
thank you what was it like having to
look in the mirror with both hands on
that
on that armoire and say
i'm not i'm not making it it was scary
because
it was one of those things where you
know i wanted to be
i didn't want to have any issues you
know i didn't
want to have to deal with them and i
just thought that we could make it
you know for so long and then after a
while it just came to a point where we
hit a wall
yeah and once that wall hit it hit hard
and um
i knew we had to do something different
and i just remember her
bringing up dave a few years ago and i
said you know what let's try something
different let's inject something
new into our lifestyle yeah and um
and then go 110 on it yeah yeah cool
well the beautiful thing about being
sick and tired of being sick and tired
you're ready to change your life
absolutely and you reached that point
where you said that's it i've had it
yeah whatever we got to do and you kind
of have to surrender it's like what have
we got today
what do we got to do and i've been there
most people have been there in different
areas of our lives but certainly money's
a big one and
and the debt thing okay i quit i'm going
to quit trying to figure this out by
myself what have i got to do
yeah because what the way up what i've
been doing sucks
and uh man you just reached that point
and it's not a matter call it name
calling or something it's not a shaming
thing
it's just you it's just a reality and
you're going this something's just got a
freaking change here
yeah yeah i think for us too real
quickly was we
actually went on your daughter's show oh
um
like roughly the first few months that
we had started there she is and
i remember listening to the podcast some
months later and you had asked
someone had called in and they're like i
wonder what that couple from the
christmas show if they stuck with that
budget and how they're doing
and we were telling some people here
tell us like if they call us we gotta
like be
doing this like we can't have them call
and say sojovers what's the status and
we're like
we quit halfway through we're failures
yeah no that wouldn't work
yeah yeah it's a different kind of
accountability
being on the rachel cruz show yeah let
me put you on the spot well way to go
you guys you brought the kiddos what are
their names and ages
we have joslyn who just turned eight
recently and jeffrey who's about to turn
12.
great they're very nervous very cool
they're gonna do great we got a copy of
a legacy journey for you that's your
next
stage and one of the total money
makeover for you to give away
so 78 000 paid off in 30 months making
95 to 115 barry amber
jeff and jocelyn count it down let's
hear a debt-free scream
ready three two one
we're debt-free
[Music]
that's why i come down here every day
awesome
so cool this is the ramsay show
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsay personality is my
co-host today
you can join him on the dr john deloney
show which is a
massively popular podcast produced by
the ramsey networks here
at a uh call in at
two ninety one eight 844-693-3291 four
six nine three three two nine one
or email and uh kelly will get back with
you and set you up to be on the show
uh email at ask john ramsey solutions
dot com ask
john ramsey solutions solutions.com
lindsay is with us lindsay's in houston
texas hi lindsay how are you
doing well i'm excited to be on just a
little bit nervous but thank you for
having me
well we're honored to have you um
well i completed spu in 2017 and after
doing so
i paid off my car i've increased my
savings and investments
i don't have any other debt and i'm
currently renting
i am going back to school to get my phd
and my school will be completely paid
for
through grants and graduate
assistantships and i will also have a
monthly stipend but
that means i'll be on a fixed income so
um and i'm also needing to move
to august i mean to the area in august
and
so the rental rates are pretty high in
college stations so i'm looking at
purchasing my parents are offering
they're being extremely generous and
offering to help me buy a house they're
actually
also debt-free and went there to see you
in 2014 to do their debt free screen
cool so you're going to a m to get a phd
in what
uh educational psychology and then what
are you going to do
i want to teach at the college level
where at a
m i don't know how long does a phd
program take
i'll be there for three years don't buy
a house
okay that was my question okay because
you
listen a phd program i don't know
anything about it i've only got one and
you know i've got a phd in dunb but
john's got a couple of them and i
rumor is it that they're tough to get
it's a lot of work the jobs after no no
the getting of the degree the whole
process that the dissertation the whole
thing right
yes yeah and then being an educational
psychologist that's a
yeah to get it to get a 10-year track
job it's gonna be tough and you know
that walking into it
but the chances of you landing in
college station
and and working there after that degree
are very very small
i don't want you concentrating on home
ownership i want you concentrating on
the completion of the phd
and then quickly moving to the place
that gives you a job that's right
okay and that was my question was with
the short-term nature if it was smart
to buy or not exactly it's college town
it's college town and college towns are
college towns uh
you know they're going to go through a
metamorphosis in the next five years
because people are not going to college
like they used to
right so it's going to affect real
estate in a small town like college
station
in a major way yeah okay
okay yeah i do have one other question
should i stop
do i know it sounds silly but do i stop
contributing to my roth ira since i'm
going to be on such a sick system or do
i try
as best i can to continue that your
stipend do you have to pay taxes on that
is that a fi is that considered earned
income
it is yeah okay then you then you do
have an earned income you can do a roth
you can only do a roth though if you are
guaranteed that you're not going to have
any debt
due to this education because i want you
to i want you to invest in you before
you invest in mutual funds
right okay yeah i should not have
everything should be
um covered because i'm technically
working as well for the university
and that's paying for my school yeah and
if that ended what would you do
uh if then paying for me ended yeah
i would have to get another job yeah
okay
and so you you you'd find another way to
pay for you know i i don't mind if you
if you stop your your retirement
temporarily and pile up cash to complete
this
this education and not that you're
necessarily gonna need the cash
but if you end up with 15 or 20 000
bucks or 50 000 bucks or whatever in a
savings account when you come out it's
not going to kill you
no that's that's your house down payment
yeah right if wherever whatever you're
going to live or you roll that over into
your retirement once you get settled
somewhere yeah you know that that's
that's the process hey but that's man
talk about
you doing it right there's not that's an
outstanding school it's an outstanding
program one of my
mentors graduated from that very program
from that very school it is top notch
and you get well and when you can get a
fellowship like that and they pay you
something you get through that debt free
you you've won
that's the touchdown that's outstanding
touchdown aggies good for you
reggie is with us reggie's in
chattanooga hi reggie how are you
hey thank you dave for taking my phone
call sure
the question i have for you sir is your
investor pro
smart investor pro one on your website
look for some in my area
found a handful of them one actually
maybe maybe not a mile away from me
what process do you use to find and
endorse
a small investor pro and
is there a number that i can call with
your company if i choose to use an
investor with you okay well smart vista
pros
don't work for us they
are independent financial advisors
we vet them meaning we interview them
and find out about them so that we feel
good about endorsing them
does that make sense okay got you and
uh there's no one on there that we
haven't spent extensive time vetting
uh however they are humans and we are
humans and sometimes we screw that up
but not very often we've been doing it a
long time i'm very proud to endorse
the people that are smart vester pros
and um 99.9
of the time we have zero issues with
them so then it is on you to say okay
dave ramsey the guy on the radio that i
trust
has said this is a guy that he trusts
and i'm going to sit down and see if i
share that trust you don't blindly go
off of anyone's endorsement ever on
anything but it's a good way to open a
door just like if you
your friend says hey this is a good
movie and you go and the movie sucks
well next time you don't take your
friends movie advice right
but the uh the same thing so or this guy
every movie he's ever
booked every book he's ever told me to
read was a good book some his book
reading endorsement is worthless you
know that we've all got friends like
that and i'm just your friend that way
so
you still sit down use your own freaking
brain though and you interview two or
three of them for your own sake
and you decide uh does this person share
my values
do they i agree with everything dave
ramsey says and i'm following the baby
steps but this person doesn't seem to
i'm not going with that one which by the
way let us know that one and we'll
cancel that one because we
want to endorse people that are going to
tell you to do the stuff that we do
here uh and because so that you get a
consistent experience does that make
sense it does
so that's one of the things i shouldn't
see when i'm interviewing them that they
are actually going through your baby
steps correct
they should know the stuff and they
should not recommend something to you
that is
opposite of what you're hearing here
that's that would
otherwise the endorsement wouldn't make
sense it wouldn't have integrity agreed
yes yes i'm just trying to be sure what
i should be seeing and what i should be
hearing
and and you should be looking for
someone that has the heart of a teacher
you should feel uh taught and coached
not slimed yeah and there's a lot of
sliming
in the financial world a lot of sales in
this financial world but if you feel
like you got to go home and take a
shower after you
don't don't use them and reggie i'll
tell you this it
it is they are trained to to expect that
you're going to be shopping around
a close friend of mine who is a smart
investor pro i didn't even know the
smart investor pro until i started
working here
i said i need some help and he said i'm
going to walk you through our how we do
introductions
but at the end of it you need to make
sure you're comfortable with me and we
might be great friends and not
so great mixing this part of it up right
so i
feel completely at ease to walk in and
let them know hey i'm shopping around
i want to meet with a couple of people
i'm interviewing three people and i'm
gonna pick one they're not gonna get
their feelings hurt no
bring you on and you should do that with
a real estate endorsed local provider
too so you should do that
any i mean you know these are people
they're going to be teaching you
and coaching you and making suggestions
about your freaking money
so yeah you need to be real comfortable
with them and have interviewed more than
one and
don't blindly follow anything and so it
always tickles me when someone writes
this hate mail says you know i trusted
you when you endorsed such and such and
such and such heating and ear company
and
timbuk2 and i'm like yeah we checked
them out they were good folks but you're
also supposed to use your brain
right you know in the process and if
you're getting slimed and you go well
dave said
sliming is good no it's not that's not
what dave says you know i mean it's just
but you're supposed to also be grown-ups
and i'm a grown-up when i take someone's
endorsement
and um and sometimes i don't take their
endorsements seriously because i don't
think that much of that person
so you know that we all do that right
that's what you're supposed to do so
what we have here is trust and we do our
best to be
worthy of your trust uh but i can also
promise you it is a freaking imperfect
process oh my god
[Laughter]
james childs is our producer kelly
daniels our associate producer and phone
screener i'm dave ramsey your host and
we'll be back
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsey advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsay call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day
podcast wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw as the
status
symbol of choice dr john deloney ramsey
personality is
my co-host today he has the dr john
deloney show
where we he talks about all kinds of
things like anxiety
like boundaries like relationship issues
turns out psychology has a lot to do
with life and
money that's the rumor because behavior
and money
oh well they're tied together man and so
uh
that makes him valuable to have around
here and answer your questions about
what's going on in your life
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five if you wanna don't join the
dr john dolone show ever you can
send an email to ask john
ramseysolutions.com
jason's in houston texas hey jason how
are you
good how are you better than i deserve
what's up
so i run a wholesale trading business
and so i have to
spend around forty to fifty thousand
dollars per month
on inventory and so right now
i know how you feel about this but right
now i put it on a credit card
and basically it gives me around two
thousand dollars
a month in cash back and so what i do is
i just
basically live off of the cash back and
then all of my business
income i just invest it and so i was
trying to see
what the pitfalls of this are i guess
so yeah well these kinds of plans only
work if everything goes perfect
[Music]
if your sales go down four months in a
row
you're freaking bankrupt
right but i'm only buying i mean i'm 40
000
a month is only what you're buying
right or no i'm buying based on what my
customers order from me
so it's like they order first and then i
just drop ship the item to them
yeah so then why then why are you having
to borrow money
i'm not doing it to borrow money i'm
mainly just doing it because
it's saving me two thousand dollars a
month right now that's
okay so they pay you they pay you and
you can use their money to do the drop
ship you don't need to do this
yeah good don't do it anymore
you're playing with snakes son you're
gonna get bit
okay no millionaire ever said i made all
my money with cash back
on credit cards you're screwing around
with rattlesnakes and
like it's a sport your risk meter is
broken
here's a better way to think jason what
are they getting from you
no company just gives money away for fun
so
why are they giving you two thousand
dollars every month
what are they getting from you right
i guess that's my information that they
get
but they're also getting a long-term
play with you
they have their hooks in you dude
because you've normalized this in your
spirit
and in your process listen
here's the thing here's another example
okay
i used to how old are you 20 5
um 19. 19. okay
um when i i was 22 years old i started
buying real estate with nothing down
and the rent i brought in was on each
property
was more than the payment
but i was in debt up to my eyeballs on
the properties and i did not perceive
that as risk because the cash was
flowing
does that make sense and here's what i
do that's called nothing down real
estate you buy real estate with nothing
down the bank finances 100
of it because you got a deal on it and
it's the same kind of
line of thinking that you're using and
um uh
here's what i learned 10 years later
i knew i knew a whole bunch of guys they
were 40 years old 50 years old
20 years old 30 years old that we're
doing nothing down real estate
a decade later let me tell you how many
of them were not
how many of them were still doing real
estate zero
we were all out of business because we
were playing with snakes
and we got bit so here's a plan
you're obviously a great you obviously
have a good business mind
your risk meter is not functioning well
you are not perceiving the risk that you
are taking
that's what i'm saying and i didn't
either it is the beauty of youth however
um you know this is you know this is the
same i'm the same idiot that used to go
over a piece of plywood on a bicycle
that was propped up by
six bricks and with no bike helmet and
then wonder why you get all your teeth
knocked out of your head you know i'm
the same guy
the beauty of youth is you do not
perceive risk
and it just looked like fun yes and it
looked like what kind of how could this
go wrong
it can only be more awesome it could
only be better
more bricks if we get two thousand back
let's try twice as much we'll get four
thousand back well so here's what i said
stop doing this man go back to simple
old people way of thinking
and pay for your business as it goes and
then you will business your business
will survive
up and down and you will not get caught
with the last man holding the beans and
get your
dead gum head taken off by these guys i
want to lean into what you said about
this being in your spirit
because i was a executive officer i was
a nerd in college
no surprise and with the student
government and a year i was a treasurer
so i worked i ran everything through my
private credit card and accumulated the
miles and then i just got a check
reimbursement every month
and it worked great i got these miles
over here or whatever the things were
back then
and i was it was no worse to wear
the school was always going to pay me
back it's when my transmission fell out
of my 88 tursel easy hatchback
which was a dope car by the way easy
hatchback was a dope car
it was not it was awful that was
sarcastic it was like a big roller
coaster
okay yeah big roller skates pregnant
rollers um so i had this check for 500
it was supposed to go to pay this thing
off oh but i'm holding this thing
i literally did transmission yeah and
thus started
well that's the you know this is what
happens with a pyramid scheme that's
right
i was floating this one to pay for this
one trying to get this financial jenga
and it always comes crashing down it's
financial jenga and but i'm the one that
can beat it
thus is the arrogance of youth and or
just the arrogance period you don't have
to be young to be arrogant but
it helps and um and my mine caught me
years later when i brought a human into
the world right and it had
piled and kicked and moved and punted
and shifted and we can roll it over here
the debt not the human that's right
that's all that too but at some point
you pay the piper and usually
it just snowballs on you in the opposite
direction well yeah
because you do get um i'll use one of
your terms a psychological term
satiated yeah you get used to
you know uh a way of living away if you
hit the curve at 120
instead of 35 you get used to hitting
the curve at 120.
then when you hit it at 35 you feel like
you're like you like you're crawling
like who would do this because
everybody knows you can make it at 120
until you
until the tire blows that's right and
and then you figure out why the stupid
thing had a sign up that said 35
not 120. and you know when you go
rolling over the embankment or there's a
little bit of rain
and that's that there's always these
variables and so
it's the best way to get rich quick
is get rich slow
it's the proven the data proves it
that's the best way to do it because
otherwise you have to do it over and
over and over again
i know this is the ramsay show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's special savings
[Music]
[Applause]
well summer's almost here but that does
not mean
you can take a vacation from your goals
because you're a grown-up
i know the motivation to stay in tents
can be
struggling this time of year especially
when that beach trip is
right in front of you don't do it and
all the fun stuff
listen you need to stay on track you're
grown up you're not a child out for the
summer
okay i'm sorry but if you live like no
one else later you can live
and give like no one else it's about
getting the small wins that lead to big
results
over time then you can vacate any
freaking where you want any time you
want
and that's exactly what you do with
ramsay plus not the vacate but the small
wins
ramsey plus membership gives you the
best digital money courses
financial peace university and the tools
that you need to keep moving forward
like every dollar
lots of i mean it's a huge offering in
there
your goals are worth working for all
year long stay motivated with a free
trial
ramsay plus text trial to 33 789
it's a free trial text trial two three
three
seven eight nine our question of the day
comes from blinds.com find out for
yourself why
blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings you
get free samples free shipping
and with the new promos they run all the
time you save even more use the magic
word the promo code ramsay
and you'll get a deal all right today's
question comes from
travis in texas my wife and i have a lot
of resentment towards her family
because they are not supportive of her
they didn't attend her college
graduation
and at the last minute they cancelled
being at the dinner where i asked my
wife to marry me
recently we had a premature baby which
resulted in extended hospital stays and
her family never visited
this also happens around holidays and
birthdays
my wife is more hurt than matt but i
hate the way they treat her
how do we move forward with her family
i think you move forward without her
family i think her family's sending you
a lot of really clear signals that
they don't want a lot to do with you
guys and it's
everyone i know has been has struggled
with this in some form or fashion day
which is i had this picture of what i
thought it was gonna look like
when i got married and i thought our
celebrations would look like this and
they always had
two sets of grandparents there and i
always thought it would look like this
and they would
then it turns out it doesn't happen that
way and um
i think at some point you have to call
what is what is and decide are we going
to
have a relationship on their terms and
are we going to move on with our lives
mourn it be sad be broken hearted about
it and then start controlling we can
control in this deal
what do you think well that's probably
one of the deepest hurts
that's out there there is no and it hurt
and it is a um
and travis i wish i could tell you that
it wasn't um
that it was very uncommon but it's not
it's more common than uncommon what's
uncommon
is where everybody gets along remember
you told when i first met you we talked
about your kids and you said i'm friends
with all of my
in-laws and i looked at you and said you
know i wear that
twice in my life ever yeah well you know
it's also a decision
that's right uh before both sets right
you know and it really in
in our case it wasn't hard because
they're actually wonderful people and
they're fun
and you know like you know denise's uh
husband's parents
whittemores we go out for hamburgers
with them without the kids right we like
them yeah you know they're like friends
real friends and so
but we made the decision to do that
rather than go why are they over there
standing over here why are you spending
time with him
and sunday afternoons are always over
there and you know
because that's what people do is that
bull crap yeah and no wonder
you know and so shut up you know yeah
just
like don't be so dadgum needy but
there's nothing that that's the thing
and most that's what most people do and
stuff like that and something happened
here
like that it sounds like they don't like
travis i was actually thinking that they
don't like you man
that's what it sounds like but who knows
they don't approve of this marriage for
some reason or another that's what it
looks like and i don't know what that is
it could be something sick and bad yeah
or it could be
that you know whatever um but one of the
core principles
you can't make them travis you can't
make them happy no
so all you can do is just love your wife
and hug her because she's hurting
because the very people that she should
be connected to for the rest of her life
are not functional have chosen not to
connect with her they're not functional
so one of the things i is a core
principle of mine is behavior is a
language
right and so what they are look at what
they are telling you
we did this not with their mouths but
with their actions their actions
y'all are not a priority to us we don't
really care a lot about this new little
baby that's cool
we don't want to spend time with all the
holidays we don't really want to show up
at your graduation
these marker moments in your life they
are opting out of
they are telling you all you need to
know about the status of this
relationship and so what you all need to
do is spend some time grieving it
you said it it hurts bad because she's
going to want to know for the rest of
her life
what did i do yeah that my mom and dad
would do or even if you know if you
you know they go okay they i married
travis and they told me not to and they
told me they weren't going anything
she made a choice and she said yeah but
but she never dreamed they'd follow
through on it that's right and they did
so you got to grieve it and then you got
to own what comes next right yeah
and it's heartbreaking man and then hey
when you're married to this
provide some space for your wife to hurt
every christmas
and it may not be a big a big dramatic
hurt
but understand that every year this is
gonna hurt again right that doesn't go
away it just is
every mother's day every father's day it
hurts man and so provide some space
don't say things like oh you gotta get
over this it hurts it just stinks when
your mom says you know what i'd rather
sit on the couch then come see
and don't um
and i i also i mean you do what you want
to do i'm just being an old guy here
talking but
um i i i would
say if she wants to reach out to them
that's fine
uh don't tell her not to do that
absolutely not if she wants to send her
mom
flowers on mother's day do it but also
help her remember to keep her
expectations low the secret to happiness
is low expectations
you are providing a gift because it's
the right thing to do
and not because you're hoping for an roi
on yeah right but the there's not gonna
you know their track record you should
send your mom flowers but their track
record is you're not gonna hear from her
and you should send flash because it's
right and it's a way to honor or not but
don't don't don't be all
upset when they don't call because
they're probably not gonna call that's
right so but let's do it anyway you're
gonna send a graduation
card because you it's the right respect
respectful thing they're not gonna come
right
right and if i do what a bonus with a
gift and if they don't it's it's what we
knew
was headed this way i hate that people
live in this this is so much more common
than we know
yeah it's i've got you know i
i've often said sometimes the uh the
hardest stage of parenting is to parent
adult kids yeah your kids as adults
because you don't get to parent them
anymore right they have to they get to
do what they want to do
you just gotta love uh and so you have
to treat them like grown friends or
something and it's very weird and
strange
and the number of friends that i have
that
are disconnected from their grown kids
after they got married
and something went sideways is
astronomical so
who's help me with this dave because
i've wrestled with this
whose responsibility is it to mend that
is it the part of me says it's
it's the parents whose responsibility is
it to men to any relationship it cannot
be one way that's right
everybody can't be one way yeah you can
go over men men men men men men and they
look at you like you're pulling the
stress out and they
they keep shooting you in the face with
a bazooka then you know you can't mend
that
because you know that just is that's
just neediness and enabling right
and codependency out your ears yeah uh
but on on the other hand you know if
anybody
does throw a um you know throw a rope
over the fence
grab a hold of it and let's see if we
can pull together i have sat with a lot
of people who had loved what's passed
away i've never
ever heard somebody say you know we just
told each other we loved each other too
much
i said i said i was sorry too much i've
never heard that yeah i've only ever
heard
man i should've but if they just look at
you and go you're an idiot and you know
i
i don't want anything to do with you
screw you yeah i don't care how many
times you say you're sorry i don't care
how many times you say i love you i
don't care how many times you call me i
don't care what you do
you're just you know you're out of my
life hello that's that's like you know
she said she doesn't want to go out with
you son there you go so you quit walking
into traffic
and getting run over right at some point
you're doing that to yourself right yeah
and you know it's weird when it's uh
in his case or her case her parents
that's what's
you would think they would be the
grown-ups but they're often not a lot of
times they don't have the emotional
tools too
who knows how screwed up they were from
the generation before they may have to
be doing the best they can with what
they got i don't know i mean
you're just dealing you're dealing with
messed up human beings for sure and wait
what travis can control here is
his dignity continue to treat them with
honor and move on with your life man
yes that's very important to not uh
don't start
angry as you are at them for hurting
your wife that you love
you still need to not uh condone their
behavior but honor their position
fire plus fire ends up in bodies yeah
almost every bit of the time yeah it
doesn't do any good even though it's
really really tempting oh man
wow thanks for the question man so it's
a solid heartbreak it's a solid one it's
everywhere though brother
and i wish it wasn't at your place
grieve it move on man this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes
you are the next greatest generation
because you
have proven that even in adversity that
you have what it takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance career training
and a paycheck to help you avoid debt no
matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today here on the ramsey show
open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five in the
lobby of ramsey solutions
on the debt free stage kevin and lydia
are with us hey guys how are you hey we
are psych dave
awesome so good to have you guys thank
you honored to have you where do you
live
we are from just south of knoxville in a
little town called maryville tennessee
no yes sir did you know i was born in
marvel we absolutely did
i love them do they have a billboard out
there homer no they don't
well mervill is a wonderful town if
you're a yankee it's maryville
but it's marvel trust me and so i've
learned that the hard way
yeah way to go guys it's honored to have
you guys so how much debt did you pay
off
we paid off two hundred and fifteen
thousand dollars
love it and uh how long did this take
you
uh about six years okay and your range
of income during that time
starting was 80 000 uh ending was 125.
wow look at you way to go guys
so i'm gonna guess that you paid off
your house we absolutely did
i'm looking at weird people absolutely
no house payment or anything
how old are you two uh mid-thirties i'm
i'm 37 kevin's 35
and you have a paid for house what's his
house worth
320. wow look at you
[Laughter]
i love it that is so freaking cool and
what
am right on track i mean you fit all the
numbers that we typically see
very well done so tell us the story what
in the world happened
well you know what the story started in
maryville you were the commencement
speaker at our alma mater
in 2009. so you went to marvel college
we went to maryville college yeah i did
yeah
and i got an honorary doctorate you do
i'm an
honorary something or other doctor this
is dr ramsey
yeah who knew that trust me he's going
to make us all a little cocky
really cool kevin olivia that was pretty
cool because my my great grandmother
started the drama department there
wow and uh back in uh august 6 i believe
it was something like that
and uh my grandmother graduated from
there my wife my wife my
uh aunt to both my aunts graduated from
there and uh man it was like it's like a
whole family week there
awesome it was so cool to get to do that
it was quite an honor yeah so you went
to the school and went and lived in this
town both uh yeah yeah i was born in
maryville but i was raised in a small
town called van or just about 25 minutes
down the road
yeah and you know what she was uh lydia
was your asl interpreter she's an
american sign language interpreter and i
was the guy in the crowd with my arms
cross saying what's the deal
about this guy anyway you probably
remember me uh no
and i the next day we had a road trip
planned and we listened to at the time
it was a new
uh concept this audio digital book or
i'm sorry this
digital audio book that we download and
we listen to it
all the way to our trip and all the way
back
and at that time we fifteen months later
we
we paid off about thirty thousand
dollars in student debt and
yeah so we've been debt free ever since
but a few years later you know we find
the house that we want to
raise our family in and we
um absolutely just killed it and um
so fun we paid off that house 24 years
sooner than the bank wanted us to
that's how we just say that way to go
that's so
cool that is so cool so the total money
makeover with the digital download stays
on the road with you
absolutely man back to that and that
probably took a while to download back
then
yeah it did yeah on a little ipod touch
yeah
yeah playing on a cassette adapter yeah
that is so fun
yeah we had that thing on cd for a while
and then of course
when uh everything went to mp3 it was
awesome and we were able to shift it
that's so cool y'all
fun fun so what are your degrees in uh
my degree is in american sign language
interpreting course
yeah and and i'm a teacher i'm an
educator but uh
i work for a tech company now in their
professional learning space
oh that's neat very good good for you
guys i'm
so proud of you thanks excellent how
does it feel to not have a payment
in the world you know it feels great and
i mean our our goal this whole time was
getting to that baby step
seven um because that really starts us
out on the next chapter of our lives
and and that is you know we we always
like to share with folks but um
uh in in the bible we see god working
through three institutions
and or you know three human institutions
and that's fatherhood
marriage and adoption and so we wanted
to adopt and we want to help others
adopt and so starting this friday we're
going to have a couple of new kids
entering to our lives and we fully
intent to adopt them
and um our our vision is after that
we would love to just write a check
every year for someone in our church to
also do the same
they can adopt as well that is very cool
and you don't have any payments yes
which means you can actually do this
yes this is not a pipe dream you've
actually mathematically figured out this
is doable
absolutely it's easier to help people
when you aren't broke that's right
you know what a neat idea i mean people
are like everybody's got a lot of good
intentions but they don't do nothing to
get themselves in a position to be
generous like you are
i love it man and then you see the
people in your church that can write a
check to help out and you think well
that person must be a
fill in the blank own some huge business
or some nope it's two really dedicated
teachers that decided way back in the
day we're just going to live our lives
differently
six years ago we're gonna pay off our
house that's incred our house incredible
love it
all right who are your biggest
cheerleaders you know uh outside the two
of you
yeah you know we we have our our parents
here uh both both sets represented here
and
you know we love it it was my mom uh in
the mid 90s who i saw as a kid just
paying off her house before it was cool
right i mean she just absolutely paid it
off early
and that really inspired me we we saw
that it gave her so much freedom to just
pour
out on her grandkids and to her kids and
even even as a teenager i was just
sitting there thinking i want that
as well yeah but so she they they've
just been great cheerleaders for us
awesomeness so what do you tell people
the key to getting out of debt is you
guys are professionals you've done it
yeah so i would say um the key uh
is really being on the same page
whatever whatever you have to do i don't
think there's any way we could have done
this if one of us was dragging the other
in either direction not for six years um
yeah so
uh you know whatever it takes to figure
out financially
how you can make this happen um yeah
right and and dave i will always say
that my key
she is standing right here because um
i i might have been the philip fulmer on
the sideline with the playbook you know
drawing up the the plays and the
spreadsheets and all that but she was
the peyton manning on the field
doing 95 of the purchases in our family
and ensuring that we're staying
on track and she likes uh she's always
been the type
she like loves composting she loves to
see nasty things getting shrunk down
smaller and smaller and smaller and
that's exactly what she did with this
debt as well like she was the one who
said can i press the button
can let me click the button to
make that number get smaller and smaller
and smaller until
and so now it's it's zero and we are we
are so grateful for that
we'll get the kiddos into the shot their
names and ages are what
yes so this is we have sophia is our
oldest she's
10. this is benjamin he is eight
this is elliot right here who is five
and gideon who's
three all right and two more coming next
week yes sir
on saturday yes sir yeah they will be 12
and 10.
all right wow very very cool well
congratulations you guys we are so
very proud of you got a copy of the
legacy journey for you because you've
put yourself in a position to
be a legacy and live a legacy it's
beautiful
it's a great great picture of uh winning
it's absolutely amazing i'm so proud of
y'all
very very well done also a copy of the
total money makeover for you to give
away
pay it pay it forward and we appreciate
you six years
six years was it worth it absolutely
yes sir absolutely looking at you right
there it's worth it
it was worth me getting up and coming
down here today to get to meet y'all
yeah me too
pretty incredible i love looking at the
lineage between
a speech given nine years ago is gonna
impact the lives of a
12 and 10 year old two adopted tomorrow
good grief man i'm about to cry look at
that all right y'all count it down i
love it
215 000 paid off in six years making 80
to 125.
let's hear a debt free scream to god
alone be the glory three
two one we're dead
[Applause]
[Music]
man that is amazing you never know
you never know
[Applause]
this is the ramsey chef
[Music]
[Music]
homeowners insurance can be one of those
set it and forget it kind of things when
you first bought your house you may have
gone with whatever coverage your lender
suggested at the time
never thought about it again but just
because checking up on your insurance is
easy to forget doesn't mean you can
afford to forget it
smart homeowners shop coverage every two
to three years and make sure
they have the best coverage for the best
price you also
want to make sure you have the right
amount of coverage on your home because
it's gone up in
value and you might be underinsured it's
been a while since you check your
insurance talk to one of our endorsed
local provider insurance agents they're
independent agents they'll shop among a
bazillion different companies
get you the best possible deal text home
to 33
789 and talk with a trusted insurance
professional
about the right coverage for you text
home
two three three seven eight nine
sarah's in columbus ohio hi sarah
welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
so my a year ago my mom passed away
and um my dad asked me for help she left
a huge financial disaster
which shocked everybody um
and so i've been helping him over the
last year and we've paid off
36 000 in
consumer debt car loan and credit cards
good
and then um he has a house
payment he owes 21.8 on the house
and he has about 60 000 in a 401k
and his budget monthly is really tight i
have
94. at the end of the month left over
and i was thinking about pulling money
out of the 401k to pay the
house off to free up more money monthly
because there's
you know there's a four hundred dollar
dental bill
83 yes okay
yes that's what i wanted to hear let me
let me kind of walk through
how i got there so that you can decide
if you agree with your the advice i gave
you okay
um but the reason the reason yes is this
60 000 is not enough
to fix his problems
any more than forty thousand is right
his nest egg is not big enough you've
got other issues
you know because it's not six hundred
thousand it's not three hundred thousand
you follow me
the difference the of the impact that 40
will make on his life
being in the 401k versus 60 will make on
his life
the difference is not measurable it's so
small
i see what i'm saying in other words if
you told me at 40 or at 60 it wouldn't
matter it still just doesn't have enough
it's just short right
and you've done everything else you've
scratched and clawed and gotten this
other mess cleaned up good for you
you're really doing a great job helping
him thank you for doing that
um so but but uh uh
you know and you're not really pulling
money out of this 401k to live on either
are you he's not right no yeah and so
not pulling money out of 60 or not
pulling money out of 40.
versus not having a house payment at 82.
yeah get rid of the house payment that's
how i did that yeah
okay great thank you thank you for
calling
ouch yeah that hurts man so
you know if you're 20
something and you're listening to the
show right now
that 82 year old guy's supposed to
inspire you yeah to get your crap
together
so you don't end up there because a
hundred dollars a month invested from
age 25 to age 65
is one million 176 thousand dollars
one million dollars you will have if you
invest 100
between now and 65 20 years later you'll
be that guy
and that should also inspire every young
couple out there
to talk to one another so that when one
of you passes away which they will
there's not a surprise yeah
one of you handles all the money and
that one dies the other one is not only
broke but they're clueless
right and scared and terrified and thank
goodness sarah was there
right to step in and help but both of
you working the plan together working
your money together knowing what's going
on
i mean in our situation it's gotten so
freaking out of control and complicated
we have this huge family meeting that
includes the leaders of the company here
once a year if dave dies this year
here's how it's going to go down
and we go this and this and this and
this it
it's rather entertaining unless you're
me that's so sad yeah there's some
people
it's my monty python meeting i'm feeling
much better it's just a flesh wound but
yeah i'm not going but uh yeah i mean we
plan it out because
i don't want that to happen because this
is complicated for my kids to be
overwhelmed my
or their mom to be overwhelmed and uh
and so forth
uh and it's a lot of moving parts and so
it's really
everybody needs to know that's a really
good point john
all right abby is with us and let's see
here abby is in san francisco hi abby
hi dave hi dr dolan how's it going great
how can we help uh
yeah so i just wrote down one question
that i had and i would love to get your
opinion on it and i would like you to
answer it as though i was your son and
you wanted me to
and you were coaching me like that
that's how i answer them
all right awesome uh but before i
started i just wanted to mention dr d
i love your show i love the rocket
diario stickers and horse master stuff
keep it going that's all i'm gonna say
all right thank you
so i'm on baby step number three and my
safety net is fifty thousand dollars
and i will get there by the end of the
year my partner and i are moving towards
fiance status
so if we get married her combined income
will be 210
000 per year pre-tax she's having a hard
time understanding why credit cards are
bad
and why i would like not to have credit
cards in my future family
she wants to keep a credit card around
in the off chance
that we go through our emergency fund
for any reason
and her parents get sick and she really
wants to go visit them
so if i was your son how would you
address this problem with my fiance
girlfriend if she's unwilling to draw a
line with their family
and kind of basically basically told me
i'll do whatever i need to do
in order to take care of my extended
family even if it means putting my
future family in bed and stuff like that
and i just wanted to ask if dr dolani
could speak about what is uh
what is her uh uh
her cultural heritage uh we're both
indian so it's like we always take care
of our family and
all that stuff and i'm fine with that
but i'm just trying to understand
like if dr delonie had this issue how
would he deal with it how he convinced
his wife to go against the norm as well
let's talk about the money part first
well the the thing is this
where someone says if it bankrupts my
current
family because of cultural norms i'm
willing to do that to take care of my
extended family
i i i don't necessarily believe
that flex um that sounds like somebody
trying to let you know before we get
married that my family is everything to
me
and um if someone's truly saying that
then that's somebody that i'm gonna be
apprehensive about tying myself to
because they are telling me up front
you're not a judgment you're
the least important person in my life
right
of those i love you're at the bottom
right and if our kids come along
they're going to be at the bottom too
that also sounds like a grandiose
statement that somebody who's not yet
engaged not yet married makes
um i'm gonna do this and this and this
well congratulations you know you're not
right you've never held your baby right
um
but i i i think it comes back there's
there's a level of fear that she sounds
like she has
and yeah she addressed that with me as
well she said
you're asking me to do all these things
but we're not married so i'm fearful
that
if you break up then i'll be stuck in a
situation where i'm not
totally aware of how to handle it so i'm
fine with that but i'm just thinking
like if we do get made
like yeah in order for you to get
married you need to be in agreement
that's exactly right whatever whatever
the agreement is you need to be in
agreement because i'm not
you know thinking you're going to change
someone after marriage either one of you
is a bad bad bad plant that's right
but now so here here's the thing from a
reality standpoint a mathematics
standpoint
if you make 210 000 a year and you have
70 000
in your emergency fund and you still
need a credit card
as a backup for a potential emergency
that is not a mathematical fact that's a
psychosis right that's methodology
that's a ridiculous fear that is not not
based in reality right and so
that that's silly yes is what that comes
down to
so that's screaming that i've got other
kinds of
insecurities going on that we need to
understand
and sometimes that is someone a child is
told their whole life you will have have
it have a credit card for emergencies
have a credit card for emergencies
and you will take care of me and it's
just a matter of looking down at the
math no matter what happens you will
take care of me that's right
yeah they're told that too absolutely
they are so i think you got to get on
the same page man and start way
at the beginning addressing the fears
that she's bringing into this
relationship yeah
and um and you can't really expect her
to do things
that's exactly what we would do hope
that helps
feels a little vague sorry man
[Music]
this is james childs producer of the
ramsay show did you know the ramsay show
is one of the most popular podcasts in
the world
subscribe or follow today wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage
has taken the place of the bmw as the
status
symbol of choice i'm dave ramsey your
host dr john deloney ramsay personality
is
my co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight
two five five two two five that's triple
eight
eight two five five two two
five a couple of uh show notes around
here i want you guys to check on
i'm working on a project called baby
steps
millionaires people that have become
everyday millionaires by following the
baby steps
and there's a bazillion of you out there
because i've been doing this for a long
long time
if that is you get in touch with kelly
and let her know you're there
for one of our millionaire theme hours
and if you
feel so inclined do a little brief
version of your story on facebook or
instagram and put it out there and just
talk about
i became a millionaire because we
followed the steps that the folks at
ramsey teach
i'm a baby steps millionaire and
i've met tens of thousands of you over
the years
but i've never really quantified it and
i've never really publicized it
but um it's a good thing for the world
of social media to hear
that you can become
wealthy if you do the stuff that we
teach which is very basic common sense
i don't teach you anything that's rocket
science and uh we
we don't teach you anything it's not
that's rocket science but we're here to
you know what we
what we have done is we show up every
day for 30 years encouraging you to do
it
and you already knew it you have to live
on less than you make a concept congress
can't grasp i mean you already knew what
to do
and here's a fun one john credit card
debt keeps falling
and here's a sad note banks are on edge
dave i've got a kleenex if you need one
i have a tear
banks are on edge the banks are on it
americans are paying down this is uh
this is for wall street journal
americans are paying down their credit
card debt at levels not
seen in years that is good news for
everyone
but credit card issuers
large card issuers that cater to
borrowers ranging from the affluent to
the subprime
say the overall card balances and thus
the firm's interest
incomes are falling to make up for it
issuers are spending
more on marketing and they're loosening
their underwriting
standards which means that you don't
even have to be alive now and they will
issue you a credit card they don't have
underlying 100 writing standards
they just give everybody a card discover
said it's earnings
call last month that the share of card
balances that were paid off at the end
of the first quarter was the highest
level since the year 2000
capital one what's in your wallet money
said that nearly half of the credit card
balances it had
at the beginning of march were paid off
by the end of the
wow card balances at three companies
including synchron synchron synchrony i
can't even say that
which is the largest issue of store
credit cards in the us
uh the three companies say they're down
nine percent seventeen percent seven
percent in the first quarter of the year
perspective
card issuers rely on growing card usage
and balances for their revenue
they're wondering if the pandemic trends
will turn into a long-term
shift we are very focused on returning
to
growing loans i love this next line
delinquencies can't get much lower than
where they are
we can't beat people up anymore
or otherwise our loans keep shrinking
your revenues come down
margins will get worse if people don't
keep on screwing up we're gonna make
less money guys
okay guys how how can we and i love
going back to this marketing and
loosening so here's what's gonna happen
you're gonna start getting these emails
and cards in the mail saying hey
we miss you guys yep here's some more
money you can just go spend
hey dave what happens if america
collectively said whoa
we got our bell rung and we said i don't
want to be the little pig
in the straw house anymore i'm going to
get my crap together i'm going to get
out of debt and have an emergency fund
i'm going to be the little pig in the
brick house so when the
wolf comes and blows i don't have credit
card debt i don't have student loan debt
i don't have car payments i'm under
control and i got a pile of money
you know what would happen discover
would be up a creek
the economy would collapse no it
wouldn't the economy would boom
let me ask you this if you're if you get
completely out of debt
thus you have your entire income to work
with and
you have money saved for emergencies and
saved to buy things
do you then do people then spend
less over the next decade following that
or
more i know in my life we've spent more
spend more the house i bought was more
the because you're affluent
yeah you're building your you have money
you spend
and you spend so this idea that debt
drives the economy is not true
now consumption does drive the economy
but consumption increases when people
aren't broke
so the idea that getting rid of debt in
america and getting rid of this
burden on the back of everyone is
somehow going to cause
the american capitalistic system to
completely fail
is asinine because the reality is when
people get out of debt
and have money they spend more money
now they spend it differently right more
intentionally
more wisely but it's not less dollars
being spent on big screens you get nicer
bigger
more dollars being spent on the
equivalent of whatever the consumption
is
because you've got the money yep i mean
think about it if you have to really
think about the big screen and
best buy has to approve you for 90 days
same as cash and you have to go through
a uh you know an entire portfolio of
paperwork just to walk out with your big
screen you shouldn't be buying the
victory well you shouldn't be buying it
but let's say if you have to go that
versus you go
you know i want one of those uh no i
think i'll take two
and y'all just deliver it to me and
here's the money
now who spends more i mean you know no
really i mean you're not you're not
being crazy
right but the truth is that i make a lot
more money and have a lot more money
than i used to have
and i spend a lot more money than i used
to spend
well no duh you know so this this is the
most wonderful news
in the world and i wish i could take
credit for it but we're not a big enough
deal to take credit for we're a big deal
but we're not a big enough deal to shift
the whole economy yet but one of my
goals in life is to get americans to
start treating the credit card like it's
the financial cigarette
and we are on track baby but uh the
pandemic came along and helped me with
my goals
woke a bunch of you people up it slapped
the silly out of some of you
i think that i again
my friends make fun of me for being
overly optimistic all the time
but i think that all by and large people
are good and i think by and large people
um when backed into a corner go oh
okay and my hope here is
that everyone got their bell rung
nothing can happen to us we'd forgotten
911 and before that it had been
years and forgotten in 2008 right and
that everyone realized oh this can go
away overnight but this you know this
can be
a segment of america this could be their
emotional great depression yes they're
never again
right and uh hopefully and that that's
really what this article goes on to say
is happening um and all we're gonna do
around here at ramsey is just throw gas
on that fire baby absolutely
oh no i can't bear it
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children
and we had also just started a real
estate company and needed to find health
care coverage that would meet our needs
we were attracted to chm because of its
low monthly costs
and the ability to negotiate medical
costs down established in 1981
and accredited by the better business
bureau chm is here to meet the needs of
your growing family or small business
check us out at chministries.org
backslash budget
we absolutely believe in it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
this is your last week to shop our
famous ten dollar sale
learn how to make faster progress with
your money in your life when you check
out these
life-changing books you can save up to
60 percent on over
40 best-selling books
and budgeting tools like the total money
makeover or dr john deloney's new quick
read
redefining anxiety which is a national
bestseller
plus these make great gifts now we've
had ramsey books 40 of them on the
bestseller list and they're 10
each and you mix and match you can get a
half a case you can get a case people
buy the total money makeover by the case
they buy deloney's
redefining anxiety by the case and give
them out the ramsey team loves
giving this all this stuff away for half
cost we're also doing a memorial day
sale this weekend where you can get up
to 71
off kids products and bundles check out
all these deals the 10
sale the memorial day sale all at the
online store
at ramseysolutions.com before the sales
end that will be now get this done go to
ramseysolutions.com
and check out the store all kinds of fun
stuff going on
seth is with us seth is in fort smith
arkansas hi seth how are you
i'm good man how are you better than i
deserve what's up
good deal well um first off i am i say
aye
my wife and i we are newly debt free
newly as in
monday yeah free for you yes
thank you thank you it's been a
we've been scratching and clawing like
third monkey on noah's ark trying to get
out
and get our head back above water where
we need to be
and we finally done it um i have not
heard that
that is fabulous that's the most
arkansas thing i've heard
since the last time i was in arkansas so
great
i'm going to understand you know i'm
going to steal it that's a good go ahead
go ahead um i have a question about pmi
um do we
have it is that something that everybody
has if you don't do
x amount down um
does it fall off on its own that's you
know if if we do have it
um does it come off on its own do they
ever drop it do i have to request them
to drop it how to
explain pmi to me so i can get my brain
around it
okay well with a conventional loan a
fannie mae loan
uh if you put down 20 or more on the
property there is not
pmi private mortgage insurance and uh
for those of you that don't know what
seth's talking about private mortgage
insurance
does not insure you it insures the
mortgage company
you buy insurance for them so that if
they have to foreclose
and they lose money on the deal the
private mortgage
insurance company writes them a check it
is foreclosure insurance
that they make you buy because you
didn't put enough down payment to
protect them
that's what it amounts to and so uh it's
you know it's a it's a the concept is
valid
but it's you know it's not something
that's fun to pay because you get zero
benefit from it
and the mortgage company you're buying
insurance to protect your mortgage
company from you
is what amounts to so pmi is 80 loan to
value on a fannie mae a traditional
uh conventional loan they generally will
drop it but
many times forget and so if you get down
to 80
of the original amount borrowed or the
original purchase price
and they haven't dropped it i would lean
on them many times you can contact them
and if you're willing to purchase an
appraisal
that by an approved company that they do
which costs you four or five hundred
bucks
uh that that that that mortgage company
approves of
and it shows that the property has a 20
equity loan or 80 loan to value then
they will drop the pmi
they have to drop it when it gets down
to
uh 20 80 80 20 if you request it
of the original amount but for instance
the year you could pay down
the mortgage or and or the value of the
house go up
and you could get your 20 equity in
there and get rid of it on that
with fha it's technically called mip
mortgage insurance premium and it
doesn't go away ever
as long as you have an fha loan you have
mip uh and with va it's built in
it's it's not technically there but it's
built into their system so
you're you're paying for it in both of
those either way
so sometimes the way to get rid of it is
to refinance and get rid of an fha loan
but with a fact it's gonna be my next
question yeah is that what you've got as
an fha
yes yeah you're you're the only way
you're getting rid of it
unless it's one there's a few of the
newfangled ones that you can do and you
can get rid of it
uh again it's more like the fannie mae
so you may want to check with your
mortgage company just start talking to
them about it go
okay under this particular loan what
have i got to do to get rid of mip or
pmi
and they'll tell you uh you know what
their guidelines are
and if it's like you're stuck with it
forever then the way you're gonna get
rid of it is to refinance it
um and it's equal to about 75
a month per 100 000 borrowed
and so it's a lot of money monthly it
equals
you know a quarter to a half a percent
of interest is what it amounts to
and so you're getting dinged for not
having put down
a good down payment is what it comes
down to at the end of the day
um that's why we always recommend if
there's any way possible to put down 20
simply because you avoid that i hate
paying that
pmi i love not having any pmi
being able to it's more money than i
would think it was
right what you said i was thinking it's
50 bucks no it's a chunk of money
it adds up yeah it adds up to being a
substantial amount phoenix is on the
line kim's calling hi kim how are you
i'm great thank you i'm so excited to
talk to you guys so
my husband and i have been following
your principles for many many years we
are
maybe a month or two away from
being debt-free so we're super excited
about that my niece
um has had some really rough times
her mom died while she was young my
parents
raised her my mom died so my husband and
i adopted her
she just graduated college how old was
she when you adopted her
wenki 20 yes
okay yes it was an adult adoption
i got you okay and um yeah she didn't
have health insurance
and other things we wanted her to have
access to our estate so that's why we
did the adult adoption
okay um she graduated from
college with only six thousand dollars
in debt thank you
and i'm very proud of everything she's
done but she's struggling with anxiety
and what to do next how to find a job
how to even start the process and my
husband and i are professionals we can
advise her but
i'm struggling getting through i don't
know what else to do
what to say to her so when you say
you're struggling to get through
describe that to me what does that mean
you give her advice and she doesn't pay
attention you say hey let's go get
coffee and she sleeps in what does that
mean
normal teenager stuff we give her advice
she asks our advice which is wonderful
we give it and she just doesn't seem to
do anything
she's just she's 20 now so she's not
she's out of normal teenagers
yeah 23. so she's out of normal teenager
stuff she's she's in
full grown up right yeah yeah so you is
she still living with you
yeah so she graduated a week ago so
what's our degree in
um event management and tourism
that's a tough season to get it so so
back to booming industries in copenhagen
yeah so well you know it's not in clovis
but here in arizona
there's a million opportunities yeah so
she's just choosing to not go to work
yeah why how come well she
the answer i get is i'm i'm nervous i'm
anxious i don't know
if i'm gonna do the right thing i'm
gonna say the wrong things am i gonna
make a mistake
everybody makes mistakes i tell her
everybody makes mistakes if you don't
like the first job you find
learn something from it in the vine but
i can't get her to just
pull the trigger and i don't it's so
worried about her yeah so here's here's
a heartbreaking situation that you're in
um she's experienced loss like many
people
on earth will never experience right her
first caretaker
passed away her second caretaker passed
away
and then as an adult you swooped in and
at some point you're going to have to
lovingly
let her go and this is going to be hard
because you want to be that person
that's always there for her and what
you're gonna have to do is change your
definition of what there for her means
and that does not mean you can just live
at my house and and do whatever you want
that means
i'm gonna put you on a plan and you're
gonna have to move out
you're gonna have to go get a job and
then we're gonna have you over every
sunday for lunch and i'm gonna check in
with you
but you're gonna have to start learning
to fly yeah she's scared
and she's got a lot of reasons to be
scared but
anytime you jump out of the nest and
spread your wings
it's scary for her it's super scary
but she still has to jump out of the
nest that's right it doesn't mean you
don't love her when she starts to fly
[Music]
dr trondalone ramsey personality is my
co-host today i'm dave ramsey your host
open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
dayton
is with us in valparaiso indiana hi
dayton how are you
good how are you better than i deserve
what's up
well um my grandmother passed away a
couple years ago
i met i'm having trouble hearing you
you're muffled can you speak directly
into your phone please
yes is this better yes sir thank you my
grandmother passed away a couple years
ago and bless her heart and her hard
work she left um both her children and
children's children and inheritance
um so basically in the amount of 39
000 in her trust we are allowed to
receive half at age 25
and half at age 30. i turned 25
on sunday and received my first half but
approached my mother
as she is the one handling the money um
to potentially move the second
half into a non zero percent
interest rate checking account something
other than that that could
possibly not have interest kick my butt
over the next five years is your mother
the trustee
yes okay she's allowed to move it
to even a money market account obviously
that's kind of out of the question
and i just wanted some guidance on some
good um healthy
maybe fdic insured um you know
accounts that could that could maybe
help hedge against that inflation
there's not any inflation has run an
average of 4.2 percent for the last 78
years
and the interest rates on money markets
and fdic accounts
are one percent one and a half percent
you're not gonna hedge inflation with
one and a half versus four
uh you have to you would have to invest
it greater than that
to offset inflation the good news is
it's only for five more years
yeah and it's only eighteen thousand
dollars yes
okay and so if you make um
uh you know two percent or four percent
on
eighteen thousand dollars it does not
change your life in five years
one way or the other here uh so
so really i mean if you wanna get real
technical about it what she should do
but it won't um is to put it in a good
mutual fund
something even like an index fund and
just let it sit there for five years
it'll do a whole lot better
um but it's not fdic insured
and she's probably freaking out and
doesn't want to do anything she's
probably super uber conservative
it's humorous that 39 000
that small amount somebody bothered to
set up a trust for it
yeah well she did yeah
it's done though but uh the less the
lesson would be that's not worth
screwing with
you you can't you can't you can't mess
up your entire life with thirty nine
thousand dollars
yeah i mean you can have you could have
thirty nine thousand dollars worth of
regret would be the worst case scenario
but um but you know it's so i mean wow
uh but yeah i would just ask mom to put
it in an s p 500 index fund
and look at the track record on that
over the past 50 years and i think she
could be very comfortable with that or
put it in a money market at one percent
you can get that at your local bank or
credit union and that would be fdic
or fsr or ncua insured you could get
insurance on that
but you're not going to make one you may
be wanting some change or something
um which is not there's nothing
life-changing in these numbers
and you're going to go talk to your mom
and she's probably going to say no let
it go
forget it don't lose your relationship
with your mom and be dramatic and all
over
over 500 bucks over five years yeah
right it's not it's just not enough
money to
it's you know if it was 3.9 million we
can have some arguments about
where this gets invested okay because
you're starting to lose substantial
money at that point
and it's not that i'm a snob or
something like that i don't think it's
just mathematically
the difference buys a biscuit right and
she's
wrapped up into this she's got different
different hooks in this money because
it's her mom and all just
a lot a lot of emotion around this deal
i can tell because your grandmother put
it there yeah
before she passed so
yeah all right open phones at triple
eight eight two five
five two two five nick is with us nick
is in houston texas hi nick how are you
hi dave thank you for taking my call i'm
doing great how are you doing better
than i deserve what's up
so we recently parked we originally sold
a house
and i'm trying to figure out what to do
the extra equity
of the house we have 60 000 from that
house
i've been following you for the past
three years you've really changed our
life
um we just recently completed
step number three so i have a good six
months worth of income saved up
and now from step number four i
am 33 i haven't contributed anything to
my retirements
my wife works from home my company's
been
putting in they can they put in
money even if we don't master anything
nick do you guys own a house
we do we own a house yes okay so this
was a different property than you lived
in
correct all right that was our first
house this is our second house
okay cool cool well the baby steps tell
you that baby step four to put 15
of your income into retirement have you
heard that before
i have so my question is i just started
applying six percent
into a roth 401k um
but my i'm trying to figure out that
equity that we got from our
first house what to do with that 60 000.
you want to put it on baby steps
5 and 6 because you're putting 15
of your income not 6 percent into
retirement okay
you don't lump sum baby state you don't
lump sum baby step four
okay so i shouldn't take that 60 000
from the house
and just put the remaining okay
nope what's your household income uh
it's 110. okay all right
so you need 17 000 a year going into
something between you and your wife
and she has a 401k available you don't
have you don't have a retirement plan
available at work
i do i have a i don't have a 401k
available at work but it's just uh it's
one of those you know funds that you
pick a year
you're going to retire and you
contribute to that
target date yeah okay do you still owe
money on your mortgage
yeah oh yeah we have money on mortgage
we just got it um you got children the
other part of that
we do yeah we have we have three
children i have a 13 year old with three
year olds and a newborn
wonderful i would i would use some of
this i would sit down with your smart
investor pro i would use some of your 60
000 towards setting up their colleges
you might do 10 each for fun so my uh my
wife actually
my wife's uh mother just passed away
this past year
and uh left her some money and
that money's in the broker's firm that's
an inherited ira
um it's uh somewhere around 130 or 140
000
how much do you owe in your home
uh we owe um
we have 240 000 loans you almost pay it
off
so i guess my question is because we
have kids
shouldn't we take a portion of that and
put it into 529's or something yeah so
at least
portion of the portion of 60 000 from
the house sale
baby step five is kids college that's
what i said just use some of it sit down
with your smart investor pro put 10 each
aside maybe in a 529 for each kid
that'll leave you
that puts 30 in there as young as they
are they get you a good start and start
doing some monthly on that in addition
and the smartvestor pro can help you
calculate exactly how much you need to
be doing to have a fully funded college
fund for each kid based on their age
and then throw the rest of it at your
mortgage and
uh when you get within reach of that
inherited ira and pay that mortgage off
i'd cash that ira out they inherited one
and pay their mortgage off now i don't
cash out normal iras or 401ks to do that
at your age but that inherited ira has a
10-year rule on it anyway you're
required to pull a tenth of it out
every year under the new law and so as
you pull it out throw
it at the mortgage they'll put throw it
to pay taxes throw it at the mortgage
and then back to your baby step four you
need to get
17 000 a year 15 of 110
going into some combination of you and
your wives
and you're still using pronouns as if
you two aren't married
uh it's our money our house
our retirement and our kids and our
inheritance and our
and we my wife inherited money so we
have
an inherited ira now it's not like she
gets to set that over there on the side
and you know that's not what that's not
how this works don't over
complicate this yeah just make it real
clean real simple it's one pool of money
one percentage for the whole house and
so if most of the retirement is in her
name it doesn't matter you've got rights
to it by marriage and by
wills and everything else so you need to
always have a will but
you know let's let's get this smoothed
out here and the 60 000 gives you the
opportunity to do it
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day proverbs 13 20
walk with the wise and become
wise for a companion of fools
suffers harm john maxwell says a man
must be big enough to admit his mistakes
smart enough to profit from them and
strong enough to correct
them there you go open phones this hour
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host you jump in we'll talk about
your life and your money carlos is in
san jose california hi carlos how are
you
good how are you dave better than i
deserve what's up
hi um i just want some clarification
i've been seeing you for about
past couple months now and i've made
some mistakes in my life so i
just want to do it right this time so my
wife and i
uh i'm 31 my wife is 33 and we have a 16
month old baby
congratulations thank you thank you
appreciate it
we just received our federal tax today
after eight weeks of waiting
and i'm in a unique situation i can
actually pay off my car today
we are about twenty thousand dollars i
made a mistake of getting the fleece
and then i heard you like me i thought
me and acro were me and
were best friends i guess not so
um right now i currently hold about
thirty two thousand our savings account
twelve thousands in our checking and
another four thousand in a separate
checking account
so i just want to make sure i'm just
doing this right i know what you're
going to say
you're going to say pay off this card
today and um
start saving up for a house why wouldn't
you i live in the bay area
you know it's a little expensive so
i just want to make sure i'm just doing
the steps correctly what's your
household income
um so my wife makes about 50
000 a year and i just started a
part-time job
i take care of my daughter during the
day so i
only make 18.50 per hour
so i know i need to bring my income up
especially living in the bay area
but we're working towards that so um i
just wanted
so um so what's the car what does it
take to pay the car off
uh today will be about twenty thousand
three hundred and eleven dollars
twenty eight thousand yes sir and your
household income is
fifty uh yes sir right now yeah unless
your household income is going to go up
probably ought to sell the car
is your household income going to go up
uh
the answer is yes the correct answer is
yes
yes yeah so pay the car off today you're
right
you knew what to do but um you know
here's the thing
you live in uh one of the four
most expensive areas in america to live
yes sir
and you make a below average income for
america
household income in the most expensive
area
so the this this is the mathematics of
that statement
are very strenuous on your house hold
yeah
what does your wife do man uh she
she works at the clinic she's a front
desk she makes um
okay so you guys are gonna have to get
careers
going that match the expensive area that
you live in
or you need to consider relocating
yes okay it's okay there's no shame in
making 50
but when you make 50 and housing and
other living expenses in the
in the bay area in the san jose market i
mean freaking silicon valley i mean
you know this is unbelievably expensive
manhattan yeah um you know la
uh san fran downtown and silicon valley
i mean these are these are
um unbelievably expensive areas and
and so uh you can do it but that most
people that are doing it are doing it on
double or triple what you guys are
making
of course and so i'm just you know
and the car doesn't fit in this equation
so i i think the car yeah yes i'd pay
your car off
and you can always sell it later if you
want to so there's no harm in paying it
off today
and but but you know don't be sitting
any this exact spot
income wise uh
and be still sitting here wondering why
you have no money three years from now
and because i've already just told you
why you'll have no money i want you all
to have a great conversation about
is living in this cool place with
nothing
worth worth yeah or do we move to kansas
and make the same amount of money it
goes a lot further we don't have the bay
side but we've got
life we can breathe we can go have some
good times and fill in the blank right
whatever that looks like but i wanna i
want y'all to have a a dreaming
conversation about where else could you
go or even if you
you know you you love that particular
area but you just move
100 miles from there and have a very
similar climb
climate and so forth but a completely
different
set of economics um because it's just
it's just prohibitive to think about
buying a home
in where you are with that kind of
income right it's you don't get a pass
on math because you live in california
it's still there so that's what it comes
down to aaron's with us in new york city
speaking of expensive hi erin how are
you
good dave how are you better than i
deserve how can we help
all right i'll try and keep it uh simple
and sweet to the point i'm uh
22 years old uh ever since i graduated
high school i've worked in a
very specific field of heavy
construction and i make about 100
to 150 000 a year and this year
with all the overtime so far i'm
actually already at about 110
so i'm on track for about 200 to 240
this year i'm very very
do you do um
i almost don't want to say it so other
people don't jump in the career field no
very specific specialized sort of
welding that we do out here
that is wonderful i'm so proud of you
awesome that is amazing
my friend mike rowe thinks you're
absolutely a stud and i agree with him
well thank you very much i'm actually in
the city right now just working day and
night so
in between shifts right now but i'm bad
well my question my question was uh
i still live at home i have about 80 000
in the bank
i have about 90 000 in an annuity
through work and about another 25 000 in
a traditional ira
that i set up last year or no not last
year i
love you and um i was just wondering
what the next move is i
i love that i'm in the position i'm in
but it's also a lot you know
i don't really have anyone similar my
age to talk to about it
yeah i don't you you don't have many
people anywhere to talk to good for you
man yeah because you have more common
sense than the average eight americans
put together
you're amazing good for you man man
you're a stud
all right so um
all right in the in the multitude of in
the multitude of counsel there's wisdom
the bible says and so you're making
enough money and you're doing very well
that you need to start putting some
experts in your life
that have the heart of a teacher so get
online and get a smart investor pro and
go meet with them
and begin to map out what some of your
goals are for
your investing um you can get online and
even start talking about having a will
everyone should have one regardless of
their age if they're 18 years old
or older and that's an expert you start
to put the financial people in your life
that will advise you because they do
know people like you
they do know people that have more money
than you and less money than you and
they can
teach you and say well here's what one
of my clients did and here's an idea for
you to think about and
they can teach you you don't do it
because they said to you do it because
you learn
from them okay um
if i were in your shoes i would put a
date certain
on the calendar that i'm moving out
okay and that can be that can be to a
rental it's okay
and i didn't i didn't give you the date
uh but it doesn't need to be four years
it'll be good for you as a young man
emotionally
and that's making all this money to not
be living in his mommy's basement
right okay it's not it's not like you're
a bad guy it's not like you're weak or
something like that
but i don't want this to have no end
date if it's got an end date then
everybody in your house around you your
family everybody starts to plan
emotionally for the day that aaron packs
up his box of
uh soccer trophies and goes on his way
and aaron do you did you grow up
in this area uh i actually live
an hour from from where i work i
actually live in new jersey
you can live and then you can live in
the same neighborhood then i don't care
where you live but i'm just saying
get on your own pay your own light bill
buy your own food buy your own coffee
you know uh make you know that kind of
stuff lock the door when you leave
all the things that adults do and that's
going to be good for you later on now
you don't have to do it
you can do it in a year you can do it in
18 months you can do it in five months i
did not give you the date certainly it
doesn't need to be four years i didn't
say that
and i want you to start grabbing a
couple of friends that are different
than you've hung out with your whole
life
yeah and guys are gonna be able to walk
with you and teach with you in this new
place you've leveled up financially wow
and you're going to need some new eyes
and new ears around you
and we're here man you call us anytime
we're loving it we're impressed with you
you're a stud
dr john dolone good show good show james
childs and kelly daniels in the booth
i'm dave ramsey we'll be back
with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace christ
jesus
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show
if you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register
we would love for you to come to
nashville and tell dave your story
[Music]
you